Tiger king and I yeah this is a major
phenomenon that the the tiger King is
massive I think it's one of the biggest
documentary explosions in certainly
recent memory it's been a gusher for
Netflix then they decide to do a show
talking about that show and interviewing
some of the people from the show and you
get to host it
that's fantastic how did this happen uh
well I I don't know I think Ted Saran
does who runs Netflix lost a bet of some
sort no idea was Ted Saran dose yeah I
worked for Netflix a couple times and I
had a show on there at one point
and he was just very nice and I'll and
asked me if I would do it and to which I
did you know I looked like I was a Lucy
sketch saying yes and I because I was a
I liked the Sirit reason to be you know
to just have a tiny little part in it
and interview some of these people was
really fun and then people gave me such
[ __ ] for asking if Joe exotics should be
in jail right and I was like that
doesn't seem like a real hard-hitting
guy thought that was a rude question
they were like how dare you how dare you
and I was like 19 felonies animal loose
and they it was a weird thing because I
think people see them as characters and
not necessarily as human beings one of
the things I had questions I had for you
was you know you actually getting to
talk to these people and be around them
a lot do you find yourself starting to
empathize with them a little bit to the
point that you think hey I've got a
little property I could have I could own
a tiger do you see yourself going that
way in the near future
uh I yes I only want like tigers that
are two and a half years old I want them
to be full-grown young and very
dangerous and let them out anywhere
really I mean why not I want to be the
guy in LA whose nun who has incredibly
old Tigers
like tigers that have what they have
lost their teeth or about I don't know
how long a tiger lives but they're like
in their late 60's and they're losing
they've lost chunks of hair I will go to
the zoo they sit around my house all day
long and they just we feed them soup
that's that those are the Tigers I want
I would that sushi would be popular I
think could you imagine like the tour
guide I'm just going well that's Benny
and he's still asleep and he's been
sleeping for 15 hours and then also no
danger and no think about that that zoo
in tiger king is there constantly having
to feed them massive amounts of protein
this anytime I go to them with a bowl of
soup the tiger would be like a little
nauseous I'll be like alright alright
let me know and I'll let you know
then you come back he's like it's your
favorite it's the soft noodles you've
been doing some promotion and I want you
to explain this okay viral online this
is you promoting this show and is this
is that your your body and then I
believe you
looks like you've shaved your lower area
and written Netflix down towards the
yeah I shaved my entire body twice a day
because it grows so fast yeah I'm sorry
I just yeah look what is that this is
pornography how dare you some people
like to promote their shows and I've
heard and so I look you've been as you
know you've been on television since
1955 when you took over for Steve Allen
yeah and I this is my one shot and so
does cut to me at 8 o'clock or 9 o'clock
in a bathroom trying to write netflix on
my stomach you did this you wrote this
yourself I did I shot that alone in a
room like a serial killer and I felt
very much like it was silence at the
lamps and then the next day my kids saw
me with
shirt off and it said a Netflix still
because I was proud and they didn't even
say anything